sheffield once home to labour grandees
like
david blunkett now the party is going
downhill
they've ruled local government here for
a decade they won
back constituencies under jeremy corbyn
but this weekend
lost the council what's propelling the
swing away from
labour and round here towards parties
like the greens and lib dems
is an uncertainty about what exactly
labour under kirstarmus stands for
he might have a plan i don't know what
it is i know what the conservatives plan
is
it seems very samey there's nothing
there's nothing which is different to
what we've always done before
and if you always do what you've always
done you always get what you always got
this morning saying nothing
but trying to do something different is
removing angela rainer as part of
you taking responsibility a reshuffle of
his top team
which has begun by stripping his deputy
of the chairmanship of the party
blaming her for the election disaster
any other rule
which is supposedly to replace her i
would say
as a devotion let's be honest that would
be absolutely honest
kia sucked angela and it it's not
acceptable by the way we had some very
poor
results uh on thursday and to through
a northern working-class individual a
former carer
a former trade union official under the
bus
and say that's him taking responsibility
it's quite bizarre isn't it this
is actually a moment of danger for
kirstama
after poor election results he needs
this reshuffle to project
strength and vision not be an exercise
in
buck passing and blame games his mps
aren't altogether sure what he stands
for where he's leading them
and judging by the results neither is
the country
here in derbyshire where more than
two-thirds of the wards in this critical
midlands bellwether are now blue
the people that kierstarma needs to win
over aren't holding back
kirsten was more interested in boris
johnson's wallpaper than
real things that are happening in the
world and that's my honest opinion
labour has lost it for the working class
and there was always for the working
class people wasn't they well
i think they've really lost it and
that's where they the conservatives
have upped the seat kierstarma says he
has a mountain to climb
after losing eight councils and more
than 300 seats even ascending the
smallest of hills is taking time
sam coates sky news